if you're gonna be serious about using
markets to allocate water the first
thing you have to do is let the market
determine the price the value of water
in the West and especially in California
it really can't be overstated whether
you care about the environment what do
you care about salmon swimming in rivers
whether you care about agriculture or
whether you care about the West growing
cities water is essential to all of
these different uses Reed Watson is the
executive director at perc perc or
property and Environment Research Center
is based in Bozeman Montana and they
focus on using markets and property
rights to improve environmental quality
one of the many issues perc is currently
working on as water and more
specifically how water markets can ease
the effect of the drought in California
what we have advocated for a perk is the
use of the expanded use of water markets
can we define water rights in the state
just define them and in such a way that
they're tradable so that people can can
buy and sell water freely you have to
have markets that actually work that
allow competing users to resolve their
competition amicably and efficiently
rather than through political allocation
of water if there's anything that
history shows us from California water
law it's that political allocation of
water doesn't really work at all whether
it's the problem in Flint DC's crumbling
infrastructure
California's persistent drought or
countless other examples government
officials have continuously proven that
they don't know what they're doing when
it comes to water management the best
way I think you could facilitate water
marketing in California and throughout
the West
step1 in the subsidies even though water
scarce in California we still subsidize
agriculture we still subsidize
environmental flows through the
Endangered Species Act and sequa and
NEPA and all these alphabet soups and we
still subsidize urban water supply if
you're gonna be serious about using
markets to allocate water the first
thing you have to do is let the market
determine the price and what subsidies
are our political just distortions of
the price step two is clarify water
rights you have to know what you own in
order to trade it step three is
encourage conservation and incur
entrepreneurship right now if you
conserve water if you're if you're a
farmer or a municipality and you reduce
your water consumption
you don't necessarily market those
savings you don't necessarily get to
bank that's that conservative water and
therefore there's a disincentive to
conserve the old principle is use it or
lose it if you don't use that water
somebody else is going to so there's a
embedded disincentive or penalty for
water conservation and what we have to
do is at a state level change those
rules so that there's ability to trade
water that's conserved or Bank it
underground and groundwater aquifers
these are fairly simple straightforward
and obvious policy reforms the problem
is there's a lot of vested interest in
water there are other states in America
and countries around the world which are
using markets as a solution to water
shortage places like France where 75% of
their water services are provided by the
private sector and England where in 1989
the English government sold ten publicly
owned water companies which made way for
cleaner water and a more robust pricing
system but most notably is Australia the
poster child I would say is the
murray-darling basin in Australia where
they have completely redone how they
allocate water they do it by shares
rather than specified quantities of
water they say we're gonna give each
person a share of the available water in
a given year that way it fluctuates from
year to year but there's less
uncertainty about who owns what and who
can trade what the Murray Murray darling
in Australia is a prime example
other examples are Chile they've got a
fairly robust water market and even
domestically Colorado trades a pretty
good bit of water Montana
other western states actually have
fairly smaller but fairly efficient
water markets where different competing
water users can negotiate rather than
litigate over the scarce water that
falls in that state water markets are
Perks answer to quickly and effectively
assist California in its drought but
lots of other people have suggested
repairing and investing in new
infrastructure a lot of calls have been
made for more infrastructure
infrastructure measures four dams and
reservoirs we can build our way out of
this water crisis the
nonsense the truth matter is we
California has more water infrastructure
than than most countries and anywhere
else any other state in the country what
we can do though is is make use of
groundwater aquifers and actually lose
less water to evaporation so the extent
to which people can conserve water and
pump that saved water down into an
aquifer during wet years can be pulled
out later during dry use makes a lot of
sense it's just like a checking account
when you have good income and you've got
some extra money you scroll it away you
use it maybe if you don't have good
income later the the current structure
in California doesn't allow for that and
the solution is not to build more dams
the solution is to let people conserve
water and to pump it down into
groundwater aquifers for consumption
later doing that would make a
significant impact on the availability
of water during dry years Watson says
that even though western states are
currently experiencing an El Nino year
which means warmer and wetter weather we
shouldn't sit back and relax just yet El
Nino is great for California favors
California in terms of more moisture and
so in the short term it's going to
alleviate some of the pain and suffering
that the recent drought has has caused
but if what was if we're serious about
long term policy reforms we can't forget
about how painful that drought was just
because we have water this year the
policymakers and the water users have to
realize that you're near fluctuations
are gonna mask the overall trend which
is increasing demand for water and
decreasing supply of water so we need to
be serious about these policy reforms we
need to facilitate when you do embrace
water markets even during an El Nino
year where there seems to be enough
water to go around because we know sure
is time there's gonna be dry years ahead